after six days of uncertainty and
anguish a moment of
relief all except one of the 179 prison
guards and staff held hostage by imit in
seven prisons across Ecuador have been
released on Saturday
night a security crisis that has been
spiraling out of control has been
quelled for
now president Daniel NOOA declared a
state of War on Tuesday and designated
The Gangs as terrorist
organizations he took to the social
media platform X to congratulate the
police armed forces and the prison
authorities on a successful
operation Katherine manchado was one of
the captured guards the 25 years old
could barely contain her emotions as she
recounted the days she spent in
captivity at the Cotopaxi prison near
the capital
Kito the fear consumed me day in and day
out until I got out I thought about
hugging my fiance all the time the first
day I was hoping they let us go after a
few hours then the night came and I
understood we were not going to be let
go one of the guards died in a brief
confrontation between the police and the
IM Ates in one of the prisons but most
of the releases took place with no
incident as the prisoners let the
security forces retake control of the
jails in recent years Ecuador has been
living through an unprecedented security
crisis fueled by drug trafficking that
authorities have failed to address
turning it into one of the most
dangerous countries in Latin
America a gang leader in the turri
prison in quena who held 21 guards
hostage said the decision to release
them was an act of Peace but criticized
the government for not allowing food
water and cutting electricity inside the
prisons if the president wants us to
apologize we can apologize he won the
war but he should help us to reintegrate
into society we know we can't fight the
state and we want to adhere to its rules
but the abuse of power needs to end on
our right to live protected
the release of all the hostages is a
major political victory for president
Danielle NOOA and his promise of a
Hardline Crackdown on the gangs but it's
unlikely on its own to end a deep
security crisis that's been worsening
for years Alexander RTI Al jaaz
guil make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer